اوضاع انسانيه صعبه يعيشها سكان مخيمات
ريف حلب الشمالي الثلوج لم تتوقف خلال
ساعات الليل وغطت عدد من المخيمات في ريف
حلب الشمالي الاوضاع الانسانيه باتت صعبه
خصوصا مع الثلوج والامطار الكثيفه الذي
تساقطت خلال ساعه ليل نشاهد هنا هذه وسائل
التدفئه التي يعتمد عليها الاهالي لتامين
تدفئه غطتها الثلوج ويقول الاهاليها باتت
صعبه لتامين التدفئه لهذه الخيام في هذه
الخيام القماشيه التي يقوم الاهالي
بترميمها في كل مره مع كل الشتاء تتمزق
هذه الخيام ويقوم الاهالي باعاده ترميمها
باغطيه بلاستيكيه او اغطيه قماشيه لتفادي
دخول الامطار
ولتامين التدفئه داخلها لاطفالهم الاهالي
هنا في هذا المخيم قالوا انهم لم يناموا
خلال ساعه الليل وبقوى يعملون على
ازاله الثلوج من فوق الخيام ونقل العائلات
من الى خيمه خوفا من سقوط الخيام فوق
قاطنيها وفوق اطفالهم درجات الحراره
منخفضه جدا هنا
والاهالي يشتكون من عدم توفر وسائل
للتدفئه بشكل كبير وعدم تقديم المنظمات
الانسانيه ودعما لهم او مساعدات لهم
لتامين التدفئه فرق الدفاع المدني قالت
انها ان الهطولات الثلاجه الثلوج ان
الثلوج غطت المرتفعات الجبليه في منطقه
ريف عفرين وبالتحديد منطقتي بلبل وراجو
وتسببت بانقطاع الطرق بين هذه القرى وان
الفرق الدفاع المدني ايضا تعمل على فتح
هذه الطرقات للوصول الى المخيمات وتفقد
الاهالي فيها وتفقد الاضرار في الحقيقه
الاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه يعيشها سكان
المخيمات في كل ريف حلب الشمالي وعموم
المناطق شمال غرب سوريا والتي يقطنها نحو
مليون وثمانمائه نا في هذه المخيمات مع كل
شتاء محمد جزائري الجزيره رفع حلب